eine ungeheuerliche meldung hielte
hitlergruß skandal in münchen ein neuer
antisemitismus vorfall dort passiert im
olympiapark in münchen am rande der
leichtathletik europameisterschaft ja da
hat die israelische mannschaft den
sogenannten klar gewalten besucht den
gedenkort für des attentates auf die
israelische nationalmannschaft bei den
olympischen spielen
1972 in münchen und genau hier zeigte
gestern abend ein wachmann den
hitlergruß und zwar genau in dem moment
als das israelische sport ihm eine tour
durch den olympiapark gemacht hatte ja
es soll sich um einen arabisch stämmigen
wachmann handeln bei diesem schweren
antisemitismus vorfall in münchen klaus
das sind im grunde ja so bitter es ist
alltägliche taten in deutschland es sind
alltägliche taten und ich frage mich
einmal mehr ob wir in der lage sind
sozusagen das richtige dagegen zunehmen
ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie dieser
fall ist es der täter ermittelt ist auch
personalien festgestellt und so weiter
ich bin mal gespannt wie das ausgeht
dieses strafmaß für so etwas wie
immerhin zum glück als straftat
kategorisieren das strafmaß ist
irgendwas zwischen geldstrafe und drei
jahren freiheitsstrafe und mein
dringlicher wunsch wäre dass die
maximale hatte des gesetzes angewandt
wird denn was mir angst macht ist dass
offenbar immer mehr leute glauben dass
das so geht in der öffentlichkeit dass
man das machen kann dass das so ist als
würde man sich zu bewussten irgendwas
macht man heute halt mal den hitlergruß
das ist so normal wird und das ist ja
genau das gegenteil und wir können nur
durch die sanktionen als gesellschaft
durch die sanktionen darauf einwirken
dass das sich weniger weitaus prägt und
das ist ein arabisch stämmiger
täter ist verbindet ihn ja in einer ganz
gruseligen art und weise mit dem
palästinenserpräsidenten bei scholz also
innerhalb von wenigen stunden sind in
unserem land zwei unglaubliche
antisemitische taten begangen worden die
eine auf höchster politischer bühne
unwidersprochen und die andere in aller
öffentlichkeit
auch unwidersprochen und das ist schon
etwas wo wir ganz klar sagen so geht es
nicht und das sagen wir ja auch dauernd
wir sagen es dauert nie wieder und wir
müssen uns schildern die gesellschaft
und zivilcourage wo war denn die
zivilcourage von olaf scholz wo war denn
die zivilcourage
da gab es wohl ein es gab ja leute die
gesagt haben er hat das gemacht und er
war es auch bezeugen das sind die
eigentlichen helden und jetzt muss die
justiz sozusagen zu einem urteil kommen
dass am oberen rand der möglichkeiten
ist ich bin weit davon entfernt zu sagen
dann muss jetzt für immer ins gefängnis
oder so was ja dann verrutscht einem die
palette der aber wenn das ausgeht mit
drei tagessätzen á 10 euro dann sagen
wir als als staat auch naja ist ja nicht
so schlimm und das darf nicht passieren
danke an claus strunz
[Musik]